ich denke manchmal dieses eingreifen
maya-kalender den roma im finger krumm
so in meine oma das war eine marke der
diesen kalender durch bradl hätte die
nackerten madl gesenkt und dann hätte
ich gesagt molly nicht zumuten
meine oma hätte diese sexuelle
komponente vor dem kalender die sätze
überhaupt nicht kapiert seit die
connection plus ging das genau als
einmal gehört
es war eine marke mini gauck hat mit der
frau wirklich die hat ja immer ich
wollte so nicht nehmen lassen wird immer
mein zimmer auf krank und die wird es
aber nicht ich wollte nicht dass die
idee frau in meinem zimmer darüber
umeinander wird aber na dann muss er sei
absurd kommt so jeder concorde suche
habe keine freunde liegen dann doch
einmal was siehst du ist nichts
definitiv nicht dass wirklich etwas
besessen davon dass sie mein zimmer
aufwand und jetzt war es erneut der wahl
da war in der schule war ich vor mir
doch in der schule ich war vielleicht so
das wort die dritte klasse und man hat
man sparen überall 15 genau überein
stimmt jetzt betritt
und da
und doktorand sie mein zimmer auf seiner
nase und jetzt hochzeit untermain mit
mein gott zu sechs lüfter gefunden
nix schlimmes wirklich nicht das waren
mit hardcore oder irgendwas überhaupt
nicht das waren so heftig weil wir
müssen damals für bargeld am kiosk afx
china
wenn man die kosten so zu wochenend
praline oder quick warst einfach so
hilft wo etwa kathy madl drin war mein
gott jetzt hat die kunden blättert
otto-katalog wintermäntel ausgeschnitten
und trotzdem die nackerten madl in die
hälfte drauf packt was das die oliver
capcom die kommen
foto schubert was denkt man noch
sozialer die frau die frau war nicht
ganz ohne ist und die hat ja immer
lauter zeigt die hat immer mein opa als
ihr mann hat sie immer quantya gericht
jeden augen trotzdem das quartier krieg
das auch etwas kater wieder in der
friedensarbeit gang ist dass er wohl
schönsten ozean kaputt jeden abend hat
es ja nie gericht neben peter sein stuhl
gehabt und da hat sie sagen immer
draufgelegt einen richtigen reihenfolge
was erst die socken dann die schuhe was
hast du nix ist und deshalb wirklich
jeden abend prozess macht an einem abend
nicht da war meine oma kranke sind
nichts gerichten kindern
es ist mein opa in der frühe sage und
schreibe nackert in baku
und der hat am schalter bei der hypo
bank war lippi hast
ja
so war was los in der filiale wird bis
transportieren am anfang ist gar nicht
auf touren
erst wird das namensschild gemacht hat
allerdings waren die zu schlimm war es
nicht so schlimm
mehr europas